never put anything on your car that
causes controversy
like ronnie's got like what is it nascar
and all that crap right
you know it's him here's the back of
ronnie's car here's what he's got
he's got a skull with like wings coming
out of the skull's ears
which i don't even understand what does
that mean it's like a hells angels thing
i guess or something i mean i don't know
it looks like a biker thing okay
serious satellite radio with the little
dog nascar in american tradition
then he's got another nascar then he's
got the american flag then he's got
something
z28 or z8 what is z8
what's this one mean which one this one
dale earnhardt jr
oh how do you get daley earnhardt out of
eight and a two
eight it's e that's a big it's an e with
an eight it's earnhardt
it's an e with an eight yeah that's no
it's a big e that's what it is
and the other one is 20 is tony stewart
look what's going on
why do you have to have everything on
the window one thing would be kind of
cool like in the corner
maybe yeah but maybe how much that car
cost you
brand new truck is 55 grand jesus what a
way to waste 55 grand and ruin a car
why did they come off i could take them
off they peel right off you have no
taste by the way man next limit now what
i'm designing the thing and i'm going to
design and what are you talking about
the heating system you know what people
get it
you're going to have to put it like this
i don't know where he gets these cars
these limos
dude you talking you and a guy no no no
no no no no this is something to do
with the guy dude i've never seen heat
like this it sounds like a
a a plane engine really and you put it
on there's no like low
it's just like nice and loud and it's
like a an engine on a car
it's so noisy this guy when i first met
him he had playboy mud flaps
he didn't know what he played everything
playboy napkins
and look what he did what kind of this
is an escalade right yeah look at that's
a beautiful car
ext pickup truck look what he did to it
that really is uglier